seeing some young 20 year old come in
with a backpack that was the most
surprising thing
you go to meetings but you see these
people
coming in with backpacks and they're so
nervous in that first meeting right
and then five years later i'm helping
them sell their company for 40 million
right it's that's the best feeling
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
what is it like being a start-up lawyer
today i'm joined by mittal makadia
partner of grayasha llp mittal makaria
is a partner at greyasha
and co-founder of solved4 a
cost-effective alternative dispute
resolution service aimed at founders and
startups
her practice is focused on representing
technology startups and startup founders
she provides council on a variety of
corporate and transactional matters
and negotiates and structures equity
financing m a transactions
and commercial and intellectual property
transactions for her clients
at techcrunch verified expert lawyer
mitchell is passionate about
helping startups succeed by equipping
founders with the legal tools and
knowledge they need
to support their employees protect
business relationships and drive growth
metal machidia thank you so much for
joining me for 20 minute leaders all the
way from fremont correct
uh milpitas yes but thank you for having
me i'm excited
looking forward i'm really excited for
these next 20 minutes talking about
you know the intersection between law
and entrepreneurship
and i've had a lot of entrepreneurs here
i've had a lot of investors here a lot
of
technology leaders non-technology
leaders i haven't had many lawyers and
i'm excited no not yet here in the
ecosystem
a hundred percent and i'm especially
excited now to
to hear a little bit from your insight
both your own journey becoming a partner
at gorilla shaw but also
you know things that you're observing
things that you're saying and and
you know as a young entrepreneur how can
i best navigate
you know my experiences from the lenses
of somebody that is seeing some of these
disputes and seeing some of the
the things that are happening so mythal
tell me a little bit about
yourself who are you uh sure i'm a
partner at a boutique firm in cupertino
in the bay area in silicon valley so uh
but most of my work is representing um
tech startups about 80 of my work i
would say is representing
and i represent you know anywhere from
the
single bootstrapped founder all the way
to
you know large corporation a
venture-backed uh you know
vc funded and uh
hundreds of employees so wow it's really
we run the gamut
and we do uh everything from you know
incorporation to their commercial
contract work
to their deal work most of my focus is
on
financings and m a transaction but wow
you know at girlshow we wear many hats
we i'd we like to say that we're
essentially
outside general counsel for companies
that can't afford general counsel yet
and so um at the start of you know when
you're when you're working with startups
you kind of have to wear many houses
many ceos the startups will tell you
they wear many hats
we do the same thing here so we do
everything from their
corporate work their commercial contract
work um their litigation which i'm not a
litigator but
that does happen and um an ip work you
know patents trademark
kind of the whole the whole cabinet if
there's a building lease you need
reviewed i'll review it
and so wonderful yeah we we help our our
clients achieve what they what they want
to achieve and uh
help them fundraise and help them get
sold too
well i think one of the things we don't
do ipos but short of that
one of the things that i'm hearing
automatically is this idea that you know
you're listing a lot of the different
things that you're doing a lot of these
things are probably things that i
wouldn't even
know to list out off the top of my head
that i might need
as a young entrepreneur and and i think
that that's that's a huge part of it is
this idea that
you know you're a partner you're an
outsourced general counsel you're an
outside general counsel that is
providing similar services and
as a founder you know i know how how
sort how you know illiterate i have to
say i am with
the legal things that i would i'm gonna
have to do and i'm imagining myself
creating a company no soon
and i'm trying to figure out how the
hell am i gonna get all this information
and how how am i going to know what i
need to do
and so yes there's
go ahead there there are there are a lot
of there's a lot of information out
there
and as you can attest when you're a ceo
there's many hats that you can you have
to wear but also there's a lot of topics
that you can delve into
right you can you can really go down the
rabbit hole
and delve into how to how to best hire
hiring practices how to recruit
you know how to do marketing how to you
know your product development your ip
um legal is one side of it obviously but
uh
and on any given day as an entrepreneur
you're trying to decide you know
what to devote your your time and energy
and so hopefully the legal is one aspect
that we can take off your plate
definitely and so
tell me a little bit about your own
journey how you got to guerilla shawn
and how you even got to knowing that you
want to be
to be in this space
uh i actually fell into it i was right
after law school i was in new york and i
was doing um public company securities
work at the the larger firms in new york
and in dc
and um i i got married and i moved out
here
and i thought that's the kind of work i
would continue to do right i
i wanted to go in-house and i wanted to
to do public company securities work
and of course that was i think 2011 2010
and
that was not an option those were not
good times for
for lawyers or really anyone in the
finance industry right
so um i like to say when
when i was in new york um in dc you
could feel
the um the stress and
and the anxiety i would say cab drivers
were depressed
in new york wow during that time and
then i came here
and it was another world right it's
there's excitement there's a hope and
i don't want to go you know say too much
about silicon valley here but
obviously that exists all over the world
now but uh but back then it was it was
really
an exciting time and on a fluke i i
applied at guerilla shaw thinking
it would just be a temporary stop i i
didn't have
i wasn't focused on startups at that
time
but one week there and you know you fall
in love you love it and you fall in love
it's just
you're working with people who actually
are putting their blood sweat
and tears right into into the work
you're not just representing
or in daily contact with some mid-level
v you know
vp at a large bank or a large
corporation you're
you're actually you and i get to know my
clients right i become friends with them
i want to know what's going on in their
lives
and so and i can do that here and i can
help them and that's
that's that's the greatest feeling and
so yeah i like i
started doing the startup work and i
love it
and so when you join real time what i'm
hearing is that
you didn't care too much about the
startup ecosystem you weren't
living and breathing the startup
ecosystem it's something that you you
discovered after you joined and then you
fell in love with it right
yeah and i come from a family of doctors
right you're an indian american here
you're gonna be a doctor and so no i had
i never had knew anybody who
uh who had done a startup or working at
a startup or really software engineers
what surprised you coming in from new
york
it's coming in from new york in dc what
what surprised you about
you know about what's happening here
about this ecosystem and maybe about
behavior of people all of a sudden
you're not dealing with
top execs you know in suits you're
dealing with sometimes
young people you know 20 year olds with
t-shirts
that are saying like hey we have this
really cool idea we have we can have
some money
we don't really know what to do with it
that's my favorite part honestly seeing
seeing some young 20 year old come in
with a backpack that was the most
surprising thing
you go to meetings but you see these
people
coming in with backpacks and they're so
nervous in that first meeting right
and then five years later i'm helping
them sell their company for 40 million
right it's
uh that's the best feeling and then
seeing their progression
right and so you know they didn't come
back after that
as well the serial entrepreneurs once
you've been kind of bit
bitten by the uh entrepreneur bug i
guess
um you do you know you go through the
process of getting sold
to cisco or google or facebook or
whatever
you do your stint there whether that's
two years or four years
to get your vested equity then they
leave
sometimes they leave before they even
get their full money from the
acquisition
because they they're so used to being on
their own and creating something
and it's really hard for them to then be
in this large
environment and then they come back to
me right
i just today i'm i'm doing a a financing
round for somebody who
i think his company got sold for 250
million
last week wow and he's already on he's
already like moving on
like aren't you taking a vacation what
yeah that is incredible
there's some tax reasons why he has to
park some of the money but yeah
so they're already
that that is incredible what is this
relationship like
with you and the entrepreneurs what what
do you see
come up often you know is it is it
mainly you know legal consultation
is it also understanding the world a
little bit differently
do you are you able to warn them of some
things that they might not even be
aware of how how does the relationship
work
yeah i mean a lot of it is just
educating them right
um you know technically i mean i'm
really just providing legal
advice right but a lot of it is kind of
um
i see the the norms and
what's market and so most most
entrepreneurs most startup founders they
the first time they're doing it
especially they don't quite know
you know what do i value this at how
much equity do i give obviously i can't
give those answers but i can give them
uh just general advice on on what's norm
at this stage for them in their industry
and that's right
that's valuable to clients um
and and really just kind of helping them
focus right i mean you like i said
earlier you can really just go down the
rabbit hole
on any given topic but kind of steering
them and
and saying look these are the things you
actually need to worry about
you know don't get bogged down on this
issue
and guiding them that way i think is
probably where
most of my uh my value add is in my
relationship with my clients
do you notice that and really you know
kind of showing them what's
what's ahead what the what the pitfalls
are ahead
are there common things or questions or
concerns
that you see entrepreneurs perhaps you
know young entrepreneurs
early on in their journey their first
venture some concerns that come up that
you say
wow you know this thing keeps coming up
and and
you know maybe this is something that a
lot of young entrepreneurs should be
aware of or things that they should
either be
you know not as concerned about or they
should be more thoughtful of
as they go about their journey do you
see some of these things
yeah i mean i think i think there's a
lot of
um with yc saves for example there's a
information out there and open source
documents that um
and there's a lot of you know online uh
tools for fundraising and
incorporation it's a lot of it's
automated which is great i use those
tools myself
um but but i think um
you know especially first-time
entrepreneurs they
they use these online tools but they
don't quite know what it all adds up to
at the end right yeah they don't they
don't quite know how much dilution
they've actually taken
um they're not they're not using carta
properly
so i think it's fine to to do all of
those things but keep an eye on your
solution
it's very easy to say well how can i
justify
a 10 million cap like let's let's raise
let's fundraise using just a 6 million
cap but then you
end up raising so much at the end of the
day when you
increase your evaluation cap and you do
a second round at a higher valuation
and then you finally do your series a
then there's sticker shot when they look
at
you know how much dilution they've
actually taken on
and so you know some of it is necessary
but
um but keep an eye and plan for it
you're not planning for it it's really
easy to just print out that yc safe
and sign on the dotted line and take the
check but keep an eye on it
so what i'm hearing you say here is that
you know there's a lot of tools there's
a lot of dissemination of information
things are accessible
but it's in the details at the end at
the end it's the details that count
and uh and if you don't pay attention to
the details you don't have somebody to
raise their red flag or to translate you
know what this seven page document
at the end means tangibly you know in a
liquidation event
then you kind of miss the point in a lot
of ways right
right right right and there's you know
there's a lot of information out there
so at this point if you're a founder who
doesn't understand you know liquidation
preference or who doesn't understand
some basic things like
you should get yourself educated on
those things understand the lingo a
little bit
so that um when your investors or your
lawyers or your advisors are
are trying to to tell you something uh
you actually understand it because at
the last minute there's panic right
when you're when you're actually trying
to to take that
cash or take the check um and there's
your advisors are telling you
these these are the issues and you don't
understand the lingo it's kind of hard
at that point to
get caught up right now
what happens if you know you see
things that you don't necessarily agree
with not necessarily from a professional
perspective but you're saying
guys listen i'm you know something here
doesn't seem right or maybe this
contract doesn't look good but
but the founders don't really agree or
they don't really understand is
is there does that does that happen
often does that
ever happen that does
that does and i i'm a straight shooter i
i tell it like it is i i will say
listen to me this is what you're
agreeing to i mean it's fine if this is
what you want to do at the end of the
day
i understand that's a it's a business
decision
but this is outside the norm and these
are the
these are the ways this could go wrong
and i've seen it go wrong
and you need to be careful but then i
always and i mean
i always end that kind of harsh
conversation
with but i'm not your seat i'm not the
ceo of a company i'm not the one trying
to make payroll in two weeks right
like if this is if this is what you need
to do to survive
like i get it like running a business is
hard um
and i don't want to as a lawyer i don't
want to stand in the way and say
no you absolutely should not do this
because you do have to
as a ceo you do have to manage risk
right and
um you know my job is to give you advice
and to kind of
you know show the the red warning signs
but
but i recognize that companies need to
do what they need to do to survive
as long as you know you're going into it
if you look at your you know day-to-day
or the things that you get to do now
with
with incredible people and it sounds
like you get to work with some of the
best
of the best and uh you know i'm sure
they're also just really great people to
work with
not just professionally but also
personally yeah what is the
what are what are some of the most
enjoyable pieces of your work
that i as somebody who is not a lawyer
and doesn't understand a lot of it what
am i
what what what how can i you know live
through you
you know your job it's exciting
you know it's exciting to see somebody
who's living in like a one-bedroom
apartment
and barely trying to make rent and then
to see them
make millions you know in five short
years
i love that and then i mean there's a
lot of companies that you know that do
fail obviously
but um but usually these guys land on
their feet even when that company fails
they'll just go get a job at google or
facebook right like
they'll be fine but but when you make it
it's it's really nice and it's really
nice for me to see
you know how far they've come that's
that's the most exciting thing
um right and then just you know getting
that
it's not just always about the money
right it's that validation that they get
which is really nice to see that there
are you know there's
two years ago they were struggling they
didn't know if anybody wanted this
product
and then to see happy customers see
happy investors you know the market is
happy to
to and and appreciative of what it is
they're offering
they're excited about that and that
that's amazing and that doesn't get
reported as much that kind of personal
achievement
that they feel and i'm sure that you
know that
you know closing the circle we started
by talking about you know
young entrepreneurs and and how you know
fun it is to see backpacks coming in
i'm sure that you also see them you know
grow
personally individually you know they
they mature
probably throughout a lot of these
experiences they take more
responsibilities you're seeing them hire
their first employees
on board their first investors and board
members and then
you know negotiate with some of the
greatest companies
that must be a really maturing um you
know
experience it is it is
and like i said i i have founders who
are on to their third or fourth venture
and that's great you know we i've known
them since they had little kids or
sometimes before they were even married
and then to see
and we talk about our children and the
divorces obviously
and all of it um but it but that's
yeah and then the second time they do it
they're so much smarter
they know so much um and it's just a
much more pleasant working relationship
because we've gone through all the
learning
um i love it and then it's just a matter
of trying to
navigate the vc world yeah right
i this is so great and i really want to
thank you for coming on this was
so enjoyable for me and um you know
hearing
you know that this the the amazing side
of the personality of the relationship
between
the the council and the and the
entrepreneurs i think it's just
it's so so cool i do have a few last
questions for you if you're ready for
them
sure yeah all right oh i forgot i didn't
even prepare okay let's go
favorite subject in school middle or
high school
history history yeah i like that i loved
i loved pretending like i was in the
colonial era i love this it's like a
story to me
it's like reading a story i love history
i love the
roman history the early colonial history
yeah
very very cool one of your role models
somebody that you look up to
gosh i can have to pick only one
um you know i would say my partner
david siegel he's my buddy he i've
learned so much from him
and we have a great working relationship
and i know it's weird to to have your
partner as your role model but
um but running the firm with him has
been such a
amazing learning experience and and it's
brought us so much closer but also
i think it's made me a better lawyer and
it's made me a better manager
and i and i hope to be like him one day
that's very very sweet the last question
non-committing but three words that you
would choose to describe yourself or if
i were to ask your partner
how how would you describe mythil
i actually asked them this yesterday i
asked i asked him and my husband
yesterday i'm like you two know me
better than anyone
okay and so quirky i would say i'm
pretty quirky
and silly um i think i've gotten that a
lot
from from men in my life which is not
only
i don't know if that's a compliment or
what but yeah definitely
and um what's another
uh i would say i'm a cheerleader for my
clients
right like i i'm excited for them i
i want to um i want them to do well and
i
uh i just i'm excited to help them
accomplish what they want and not just
my clients right my friends family i'm
always rooting for people and
and hoping for the best for them and
excited for that so cheerleader
probably the other word and then um
no filter i think is the third one i
have absolutely no filter i just say
whatever's on my mind
which is that's not necessarily a a good
thing
but i think it's a very very good thing
and i got it i can smell it i've tried
all it does is just it makes me
depressed when i
it makes me awkward i have to just
lean into it and go with it i love it
thank you so so much for coming on this
was so great
i look forward to sharing this thank you
for sharing your insights and your
passion on your own journey it was
really really
interesting and joyous for me to listen
to it and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you